[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 8 y
santiago lópez gonzález nuestro tema del
programa de hoy nos lleva hasta brasil
allí un juez de la corte suprema anuló
las condenas del ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva por considerar
incompetente al tribunal que el adicto
no analizó si era inocente o culpable
solo concluyó que hubo un error un error
en el procedimiento y que el juez sergio
moro no era competente para juzgarlo la
decisión provocó por supuesto un sacudón
político en brasil en donde podría
abrirse una puerta para una nueva
aspiración presidencial de lula da silva
en las elecciones del 2022 pero ojo
porque está solamente una de las
posibilidades el proceso judicial
ahora debe comenzar de nuevo en la
justicia del distrito federal aunque de
momento lula queda completamente libre
todos los cargos y sobre todo sin
impedimentos queda libre de todo para
participar en política pero falta que
esa instancia federal avale la decisión
de este juez el expresidente que ya ha
gobernado brasil en dos periodos
consecutivos desde el 2003 hasta el 2010
suma dos condenas
por el tribunal de la ciudad de curitiba
por casos vinculados a la operación
anticorrupción la valla pto que
evidenció todo un esquema de sobornos
pagados por grandes constructores a los
políticos para obtener contratos en la
petrolera estatal petrobras en sus
primeras declaraciones el ex presidente
no ha sido muy claro si aspira o no a la
presidencia pero en lo que sí se mostró
muy seguro fue en señalar y en criticar
al presidente ya ir bolsonaro aseguró
que el país está sin gobierno y criticó
el manejo que le han dado a la pandemia
del joven 19 veamos
lula reapareció en la política brasileña
luego de que el tribunal supremo anulara
las condenas que tenía el expresidente
por corrupción
luiz inácio lula da silva dijo que fue
una víctima de la injusticia
sé que fui víctima de la mayor mentira
legal en los 500 años de historia a
pesar de que la decisión de la corte le
permite ser candidato
lula dice que no piensa postularse para
las próximas elecciones presidenciales
mi cabeza no tiene tiempo para pensar en
la candidatura 2022
pero el exmandatario tampoco negó la
posibilidad de un regreso al contrario
enfatizó que quiere volver a hablar con
los brasileños para defender al país del
mal que causa ya el personal
lula le dedicó varias de sus frases al
presidente de extrema derecha y afiló
sus críticas hacia la economía y el
manejo de la pandemia hubo un presidente
que inventó la cloroquina color opina
y un presidente que dijo que los que le
tienen miedo al cob y 19 son
que el hobbit era sólo una pequeña gripe
que el kobe era algo para cobardes que
él era un ex deportista y que no le
afectaría
y ese no es el papel de un presidente de
la república en un país civilizado dice
lula habló desde la sede del sindicato
de trabajadores del metal en las afueras
de sao paulo fue justo allí donde
comenzó su campaña presidencial en 2012
antes de ser presidente durante siete
años y ahora sin condenas por corrupción
en su contra podría volver a la arena
política
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
josé eduardo cardoso el ex ministro de
justicia ex abogado de la ex presidenta
dilma rousseff y también es asesor legal
del equipo de defensa del ex presidente
lula él se encuentra en la ciudad de
brasilia y desde la ciudad de fortaleza
en el nordeste del país
aitor freire él es diputado oficialista
por el partido social liberal les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y también sus comentarios en
las redes sociales se la recuerdo
estamos en facebook y también no se
encuentran en instagram y en twitter
como france24
y sant y luego la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 pues ya tenemos el tema el
contexto de los invitados comenzamos el
debate bueno señora cardoso se lleven
viendo el programa y quiero comenzar por
preguntarle qué significado tiene para
la política brasileña esta decisión del
juez de la corte suprema que fue dada a
conocer esta semana buenas noches
buenas noches un placer estar con
ustedes complementar el parlamentario
está acá les pido perdón porque no hablo
muy bien español voy a hablar un poquito
de porteño en verdad yo de una decisión
histórica porque a muchos años la
defensa del señor presidente lula dice
que moro no tenía competencia para
decidir no tenía competencia legal no el
juez natural del proceso más él decidió
el condenó sin pruebas y más aún otro
proceso en que demostrarse en que se
demuestra perdón que él sospechó para
decidir esto aún va de ser decidido por
la fuerte suprema de brasil por eso
entonces hoy se hace un rescate
histórico un rescate de la democracia un
rescate del estado de derecho en brasil
se regata la justicia porque en un
hombre fue ha faltado de disputar a la
presidencia de la república de la
decisión de un juez arbitrario que
después se coloca que se afirma que se
cambia ministro de justicia de jair
bolsonaro
puesto derivó en un rescate histórico un
rescate de la democracia el restaurar el
derecho de la libertad de las personas
que tiene los derechos de ver sus
exposiciones público ideológicas y no
ser emitidas al cáncer por esto un
rescate de la democracia brasileña así
lo hice josé eduardo cardoso desde
brasilia desde la ciudad de fortaleza ya
lo decía yo en el nordeste
aitor frei de su opinión sobre lo que
significa este remezón político este
sacudón político para este país
suramericano con este anuncio dado a
conocer esta semana
buenas noches es un inmenso placer
hablar con todos ustedes buenas noches
míster cav 2o lo que pienso de esta
cuestión imaginen un juez de fútbol que
marca anotó un penal solamente la
segunda mitad del tiempo pero el penal
fue en el primero tiempo esto no no no
es no
esto no es lícito no es moralmente
aceptable recordando que me que el juez
serbio moro
sus decisiones fueron también realidades
por tribunales superiores y hasta en la
suprema corte también entonces es mail
la verdad que yo me siento con vergüenza
de ser brasileño con una decisión de
está elaborado fue una de las mayores
operaciones con recursos no solamente de
la historia de brasil va en todo el
mundo grandes y poderosos políticos y
emprendedores empresarios fueran
impresos y también tienen una cuestión
que en la corte suprema el no válido no
analizó el mérito del proceso solamente
la cuestión de la jurisdicción de la
competencia por tanto puede ser una
alegría algo
en un corto plazo de tiempo
señor cardoso tomando en cuenta lo que
explica el señor frei de este fallo y
está este anuncio hecho en brasil esta
semana puede revertirse porque como dice
el señor frei de no estudiaron la
conclusión de este caso sino que
estudiaron fue el procedimiento puede
haber entonces una reversa en ese caso
en todos los estado de derecho de los
justiciables instancias la primera la
segunda las cortes supremas en colombia
sres y también los estados de derecho
son así en las cortes superiores pueden
rever las decisiones de las otras
instancias un as también de fútbol
tenemos lugar que puede revivir la
decisión que lo juez equivocadamente ha
colocado de la cancha así en la suprema
corte de brasil sólo juez no va bien si
a la segunda instancia no va bien la
última instancia dice no usted no era
competente para hacer lo que quisiera
usted no tiene competencia para condenar
a alguien sin problemas
usted es sospecho creo que la suprema
corte ha hecho con
o sea se rescata la verdad yo no tengo
vergüenza de ser brasileño cuando se
está nueva democracia no se puede tener
vergüenza de su país
yo tengo vergüenza vergonza cuando se
prueba la situación de negar la ciencia
y eso yo tengo berman de vergüenza yo
tengo vergüenza cuando la virtud de
combatir la corrupción y además virtud
hecha con navegación del estado de
derecho la negación de la ley de su
tengo vergüenza para la democracia yo no
tengo vergüenza yo tengo vergüenza por
ello brasil tiene 2.000 muertes por día
con un presidente que no hace nada y que
no una trasera tras las vacunas para
brasil
esto es la verdad por tanto cada uno de
nosotros tiene que ver las horas para
invertir su verbo en vergüenzas yo tengo
y yo no tengo vergüenza de la democracia
tiene le sale derecho yo tengo la
frecuencia dieter nos tenemos hoy más de
dos brasileños corriendo de qubits
sin que el gobierno se pase
absolutamente nada de lo presidente tome
una posición razonable en este momento
señor frei de qué posibilidades tiene
dado el panorama de la justicia y en
brasil que este fallo se ha ratificado o
descartado por un tribunal federal como
debe ser que es la instancia que falta
para que todo este esta película llegue
a una conclusión es el último escenario
que un tribunal federal decida cuál cree
usted que es el escenario allí
a uno le asusta cuando el ministro
fuckin darle una decisión como esta
cuando sacamos un poco de donde el
ministro fuckin viene él fue indicado
por el partido de los trabajadores que
el partido del el presidente lula y
también mucho ligado a los movimientos
de extrema izquierda como el movimiento
sin tierra que los movimientos de
extrema extrema izquierda
ahora tenemos el plenario para validar
esta situación de la jurisdicción pero
después de esto el mismo que el plenario
el pleno los dos ministros validen la la
decisión del ministro joaquín en el
tribunal de la jurisdicción de brasilia
puede también realidad
y al comprobar que lula y esto usted ve
envolviendo en muchos casos de
corrupción
lo que dejó claro que es que
ministro fucking no válido el mérito del
proceso solamente la cuestión de la
competencia de la jurisdicción son una
no está ahí es tan libre como piensa que
es tan claro el vaya a ser su discurso y
él tiene sus electores tienen su
el pueblo para escucharlo quiere que
quieres escuchar pero yo pienso que la
justicia en brasil vaya a vencer más una
vez
freddy playas he probado que lula
siempre esté bien volviendo en muchos
casos de corrupción es señor cardoso su
opinión sobre la posibilidad de este
fallo del tribunal federal cuál puede
ser el resultado
mira yo creo que separa justicia
inclusive cuando se decir no solamente
que moro e incompetente más se dirá que
a sus pechos hoy nosotros sabemos que
existen mensajes que fueron citas
escritas entre los los fiscales y moro
que muestran claramente la persecución
política a lula que muestran claramente
que la ley no era necesario ser cumplida
que se criaron situaciones artificiales
para que la familia pudiese decir que
lula era corrupta bueno sabemos los
ministros de la suprema corte dijeron
esto hicieron evans decide ahora la
próxima semana se muere sospecho no te
mira qué curioso lo único ministro
nombrado por jair bolsonaro un ministro
que quise estudiar
o sea que quiero mirar
como decidirá el juez nombrado por
personal si el isr que moore es sospecho
esta tesis de que fuckin que una origen
de izquierda cae por tierra
mira por tanto que fue su novia que dejó
es que dice lo que quiero wilson a quien
hace justicia bueno ha hecho justicia
nuevo como que lula en la prisión
para que ayudara un pureza y disputar
las elecciones presidenciales y después
recibió un premio por sonar o gana
los ministros de justicia de personal es
claro solamente que no quiere ver esto
que os voy a un persecución política
para un proyecto político hombre the
world police que beneficio personal
tiene del presidente que hoy tenso de su
responsabilidad directa la muerte de más
de dos mil brasileños por día por fuera
se de la corrida yo cree que lo supremo
tribunal federal no va a cambiar la
decisión de ministros aquí yo creo que
el supremo tribunal federal irá en la
semana próxima dice que muro en sus
pechos y lo fuerte probablemente
decisivo para esto
y un ministro nombrado porque ayer
bolsón
sus perito hago la traducción es
sospechoso por estar implicado en una
posible trama para que quede claro lo
que está diciendo el doctor cardoso
sigo con ustedes señor cardoso para
hacer la ronda de forma inversa cuál es
el significado entonces que tiene esta
decisión en el momento político que está
viviendo brasil en este momento porque
hace unos años veíamos un partido un pp
muy desprestigiado por todos estos casos
de corrupción seriamente enlodada la
imagen del ex presidente por estos
escenarios que se presentaron pero hoy
el panorama es completamente diferente
como es el brasil político de hoy
yo tenia un cambio del escenario un
cambio político importante porque es un
absurdo imaginar que la corrupción en
brasil empezó concrete lines de
corrupción en brasil e histórica en
todas las fuerzas políticas infelizmente
lamentablemente están siempre
con alguna de sus personas vinculadas a
situación de corrupción porque por
ejemplo el gobierno persona no está en
problemas
su hijo del presidente compró una casa
de millones de dólares tengo una
explicación a otras investigaciones y lo
presidente que es para hacer porque la
policía federal nombrando un nombre no
eficiencia las investigaciones contra
sus hijos y permiten brasil está en la
realidad más las fuerzas políticas
conservadoras que tienen a expresión en
la acción de sergio mur pegaron quedaron
se fuertemente la idea de crear la
situación que debe tener el responsable
único de la corrupción no es verdad hay
errores en algún compañero de pepe tiene
que pagar más allá de errores también en
miembros de la derecha que tiene que
pagar a los jueces conducieron la
situación para pegar lo principal líder
de la historia brasileña que el blog
para que no pudiese disputar la elección
para presidente para que un otro
candidato pude ganar y esta es la
realidad y ahora las cosas se cambian
lula tiene hoy sus derechos políticos
liberados puede ser candidato si quiera
más mismo que no quiera será un peso
decisivo de la procede del proceso
electoral brasileño un peso decisivo por
eso las cuales impresión se cambian y
ahora la historia tirar o qué ocurrirá y
nuestro preso señor frei de su opinión
al respecto sobre el escenario político
de hoy en día en brasil
las elecciones municipales ahora en 2020
demostraron que el blue para el pt
partido del presidente lula fue mucho
mucho frustrado y perdió en la mayoría
de la ciudad en brasil
el pueblo blanco brasileño está cansado
de corrupción y de tantas mentiras no
logré más tantas populismos y naciones
yo no tengo criminal de mascota sí sí
hay miembros del partido desde la
familia o en la derecha próximo del
presidente por sonar que ellos también
sean juzgados y van para la prisión
no podemos tolerar la corrupción
y dejó claro que los méritos del que
lula ha hecho no fue juzgado por tanto
de esta impresión no va a cambiar
simplemente porque un juez ha dicho que
la jurisdicción desde el proceso está
equivocado
y el próximo año tenemos si elecciones
presidenciales y todo hecho ha sido ha
sido fue hecho por una cuestión de
conveniencia política simplemente porque
no existen lideran zas en brasil y ellos
quisieran rescatar un gobierno de
izquierda o un líder de izquierda pero
yo pienso que no voy a cambiar tanto es
algo que la izquierda está conmemorando
pero con corto plazo señor frei de usted
lo menciona en las elecciones regionales
en brasil el pp no ganó las grandes
capitales de los estados federados no
ganó digamos posiciones importantes a
nivel estatal y a nivel dentro de brasil
pero hay algo que hay que decir
claramente y es que la figura de lula da
silva sigue siendo una figura
predominante en la escena política
brasileña importante y que sigue
arrastrando a las masas sigue siendo un
fenómeno político una cosa muy distinta
son estas elecciones regionales y otra
cosa puede ser lula da silva como un
posible candidato a la presidencia
sí claro continúa sin un líder populista
para la izquierda él tiene si su bien 20
30 tal vez de la populación que sigue a
salud a la izquierda pero yo no pienso
que vaya a cambiar el sentimiento del
pueblo brasileño que no lo están
logrando más tanta corrupción y quiere
un país que se desenvuelva tenemos ahora
una grave crisis económica por falta de
vacunas y tenemos que enfocar en cosas
que van a resolver nuestro problema de
salud y también el problema económico
que uno está ligado al otro
y eso fue esta versión fue algo una
conveniencia política simplemente para
rescatar y tracción tal vez un nuevo
factor para la izquierda pero como allí
han dicho no acreditó que será algo
decidimos para la elección en el próximo
año señor cardoso después de darse a
conocer esta decisión de la corte
suprema la primera noticia y lo que
todos los medios salimos a publicar era
que existía esa posibilidad de que lula
da silva se presente a las elecciones
del 2022 no puede cantar victoria porque
el proceso puede volver a empezar puede
volver a ir otra vez al juzgado e
instituciones como la procuraduría
pueden empezar a hacer sus
procedimientos para para reabrir el caso
pero en otra instancia
ve usted anula a silva como candidato
para el 2022
lo que ya que esto va a depender de su
voluntad se quiere será que no quiere
vencer a tiene una grande
representatividad social líder
indiscutible de los brasileños muchos no
le gusta y ajustó el democrático va a
ser un líder yo creo que lo líder
popular más importante de la historia de
brasil cuya única manera que se encontró
para que no pudiese ganar las elecciones
pues metieron alcanza es esto qué
ocurrió bueno no es solamente
incompetente pero no es sospechoso con
justicia esté en buen español es
sospechoso las tramas de moro y después
y el ministro de justicia de bolsonaro
son muy claras sus cursos conversas con
a que les quieran los fiscales y hoy son
conocidas no se puede decir que no
cuando le dice lula es lo principal que
tenemos qué
cuando dice a los fiscales o querer y
aún para hacer para condenarlo cuando
creó situaciones mediáticas para
construir la idea de que lo gobierno
depende de demás usted era corrupto con
la nevera
todo esto está claro a todos los
brasileños entonces puede más decir que
no se conoce esto estará cada vez más
claro a todos los brasileños y este
líder y el principal líder trabajador de
la historia de brasil seguramente será
un peso decisivo en las próximas
elecciones se ganará o no ganará c-zero
judiciario a cambiar o no va a cambiar
no sé no sé si estaré vivo mañana
porque el objeto que las cosas están en
brasil las personas
las personas están aburridas el
presidente dice nada no es necesario
hacer nada no es necesario a curas
venecia bueno conocido que se haga a
mañana mañana solamente sé que la
historia y brasil empezó a ser rescatado
y la verdad ahora está metida a la luz
del sol y verdaderamente no se la
influencia de la verdad una política que
hace que la historia ahora comesa
efectivamente hacia el escrita con
letras correctas el expresidente lula da
silva ha dicho que no sabe si va a ser
candidato no ha sido muy claro ha dicho
que es decisión del partido y que lo
decidirá en el año entrante
tal vez siendo un poco
pensando en este escenario que puede
abrirse otra vez este caso a nivel
judicial y puede llevarlo a través hasta
en las cortes y volver a empezar de
nuevo y eso le impida presentarse como
candidato ya veremos qué pueda suceder
el año entrante lo que sí espero es que
el panorama para la ultraderecha
brasileña es difícil porque como ustedes
lo han mencionado la crisis económica es
importante en para sí la pandemia ha
afectado muchísimo a este país
suramericano como cae esta gota en esa
copa en ese vaso de problemas que tiene
la ultraderecha que está gobernando
brasil señor cardoso al darse a conocer
este anuncio y la libertad de lula
mira no soy vivimos lo peor momento de
la pandemia es increíble porque teníamos
condiciones de no vivir hoy esta
situación más del gobierno no ha hecho
nada el gobierno ha hecho una negación
de la ciencia el presidente no empezó a
hacer las cosas que eran necesarias para
que no llegásemos hoy al estado en que
estamos presidente decía que era una
gripe más pequeña gripe el presidente
decía que no era necesario
hacer nada porque solamente movería
vuestros 800 brasileños
toda pandemia hoy nos tenemos dos mil
muertes por día esto es una actriz
inigualable una crisis
directamente impulsión hada por un
gobierno incompetente por un gobierno
que niega la ciencia eso no sé cómo será
es imposible que siento duda poder a ser
presidente no sé
lula será candidato no sé la vida esta
incierta noble acción por esto nosotros
tenemos que luchar para que todos los
demócratas de brasil todas las personas
que depende lo que está de derecho están
juntas independientemente del nombre de
la persona que va enfrentará a ivo solar
no nos movemos más tener un
autoritarismo no podemos más tener a
alguien a alguien en brasil en negar la
ciencia no tenemos que ser alguien y
tiene respeto a la ley ya la salud de
todo lo pueblo recibe señor frei de su
opinión sobre cómo toman la ultraderecha
en brasil el partido oficialista el
gobierno esta noticia
es verdad que también es un sonado tenga
dejando pasar una gran oportunidad para
la derecha y para el pueblo
brasil amigo
no estoy aquí defendiendo el presidente
con sonar diciendo que su gestión en la
pandemia ha sido de las mejores porque
no tiene sido y tenemos el problema
también con sus hijos entonces muchos de
nosotros que somos de derechos
conservadores también estamos
descontados con el presidente y no
tenemos
no tenemos problemas en hablar esto
el presidente tiene sí xxi equivocado en
la forma que haya conducido la pandemia
tiene hoy oído muchas críticas de
nosotros también y queremos que esto se
cambie pero esto no significa que vamos
a aceptar la corrupción de volta ok
mister cardoso dice allí ha dicho que la
corrupción es un problema histórico de
brasil pero el problema del pp es porque
es un partido del presidente el 1 de iu
ha institucionalizado esta corrupción y
están ahí las muchas pruebas escuchamos
de muchos en sus acuerdos de
culpabilidad entonces
si será un gran problema para google
bolsonaro qué bien
en las elecciones y tal vez el pueblo
quiere alguien más moderado equilibrado
que tal vez no sea de los extremos si
alguien del cielo no sabemos pero si
queremos si alguien que trate de una
forma seria salud y la economía señor
frei de señor gatos o vamos llegando al
final del programa quiero tomar este
tema un poco más allá de las fronteras
de brasil esta noticia y esta liberación
de lula y la eliminación de estos cargos
por el momento hasta que llegue a esta
instancia federal y tome alguna decisión
cuál es el mensaje que envía la libertad
de lula a la izquierda latinoamericana
porque en otros países también el
presidente o ex presidente de izquierda
fue o está haciendo en este momento
juzgado por algún tipo de acusación lo
vemos en ecuador con correa lo vemos en
bolivia con evo morales vemos los casos
que hay contra cristina fernández de
kirchner en argentina y bueno los casos
pueden seguir enumerando sé cuál es el
mensaje entonces para la izquierda
latinoamericana
señor frei te comenzó por usted
la versión freighter
la mensaje es la peor posible porque
y están pasando una buena imagen que no
la ha sido absorbido de sus suscribes y
no el mérito no fue analizado no fue
buscado pues simplemente una cuestión de
jurisdicción y los ejemplos de izquierda
en el mundo son los peores posibles
mirar lo que escuchamos de como ésta ha
ido y cómo ha ido la economía de
admitida de venezuela corea del norte
cuba entonces no es la mejor posible
luna así hecho muchas cosas equivocadas
y no estamos aquí defendiendo criminal
como una mascota
tenemos que buscar esto de una forma que
de una forma seria y esperar lo mejor el
mejor de nuestro continente del américa
latina y de aquí en brasil y claro
señor cardoso para el cierre cuál es
entonces el mensaje que le envían a la
izquierda latinoamericana con este tipo
de acciones adelante
el mensaje y la democracia no perdonan
los que la violenta
siempre que la democracia violentada la
historia perseguir los que el avión
intención sea el humor violento la
democracia
el estar derecho wii está en desgracia
por sonar
violento
la democracia wind hasta la derecha
conservadora a distancia del
y lula ahora representa los eventos de
la historia que vuelven que vuelven a
sobrar en toda américa latina los
vientos de la democracia los vientos que
quieren combatir la exclusión social la
intolerancia y la opresión
es eso y símbolo y salud
bueno pues si tienen ustedes las
opiniones de josé eduardo cardoso desde
la ciudad de brasilia y aitor freire
desde la ciudad de fortaleza en el
nordeste de brasil a los dos muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado aquí en
el debate de france 24 y pues este
capítulo apenas se está comenzando a
escribir falta otra decisión a nivel
federal para poder saber qué es lo que
va a suceder con el expresidente luiz
inácio lula da silva y determinar si
puede ser o no candidato para las
elecciones del 2020 ustedes muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado y sigan
dejando sus opiniones y comentarios a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
la programación de france 24
[Música]